GREG: IT IS DONE.
YOU ONE.
IT WAS NOT ABOUT CAVANAUGH AND
IT WASN'T ABOUT THE COURT WHAT
ABOUT YOU, THE SYSTEM THAT
PROTECTS YOU AND SOMETHING
CALLED DUE PROCESS.
FIRST CONGRATS TO YOU,
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DECIDE TO BURN THE VILLAGE IN
ORDER TO SAVE IT.
BECAUSE OF THAT REPUBLICANS
FINALLY FOUND THEIR STONES.
AFTER SO MUCH LUNACY THAT WE
WERE SUPPOSED TO STOMACH BY
MEDIA WHO WOULD SWALLOW ANYTHIN
ANYTHING, LIKE "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTS THAT KAVANAUGH
WAS BREWED AN I.C.E. CUBE IN THE
GANG RAPE THING DID NOT WORK SO
THAT WAS YOUR BACKUP.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT YOU COULD NOT FIND TO BLAME
HIM FOR A WET WILLY?
[LAUGHTER]
AND THERE WOULD BE THIRD
ACCUSERS EXPLODING ALL OVER THE
PLACE MUCH LIKE MICHAEL
ASPIRATIONS.
[LAUGHTER]
HE DID MORE TO HARM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAN BILL
CLINTON'S CIGAR.
[CROWD BOOS]
MEANWHILE, THE MEDIA IGNORES
HOLES IN THE ACCUSER STORY SO
LARGE YOU COULD STEER MICHAEL
MOORE THROUGH THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
AFTER THE FBI OF EDUCATION FOUND
BUILT THE SWING VOTES WENT TO
KAVANAUGH.
LED BY SUSAN COLLINS,
REPUBLICAN, WHO WENT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR AND METHODICALLY
EXPLAINED SHE THOUGHT KAVANAUGH
WAS FIT FOR THE BENCH.
SHE SMOOTHLY DISMANTLED THE
ANTI- KAVANAUGH ARGUMENT AND
PAINTED HIM A MODERATE, ALL TO
CONVINCE THE LIBERALS THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS NOT A MONSTER AND
MORE LIKE A SMURF.
WERE THEY LISTENING?
NO, THE LEFT MONITOR BECAUSE
THEY PREFER THEIR WOMEN TO THINK
ONLY ONE WAY, THIS WAY.
[CROWD BOOS]
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: THIS IS A GREAT DAY.
KAVANAUGH AND TRUMP MAY WELL
HAVE SAVED THE COUNTRY BY
DEFEATING THE MOB.
WE ARE ALL VULNERABLE TO THE
MOB.
THE MOB IS DEFINED BY THESE
THINGS.
SUBVERSION OF JUSTICE,
PUNISHMENT WITHOUT EVIDENCE,
WILLINGNESS TO DISCARD
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS FOR IMMEDIATE
POLITICAL GAIN.
A MOB IS DEFINED NOT BY DIVERSE
VOICES BY PEOPLE IMITATING ONE
SOUND BUT THE SOUND OF RAGE.
THAT IS WHY IT IS SO SCARY.
THE MOB IS AN UNBENDING BEAST IN
WHICH INTIMIDATION IS ONLY
COMMODITY.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S NOT ABOUT
KAVANAUGH AT ALL BUT ABOUT YOU.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR KIDS, SIBLINGS,
PARENTS AND SPOUSES BECAUSE THE
MOB CAN HAPPEN TO YOU.
THIS NEXT ELECTION IS HUGE.
WE MUST TEACH THE MOB A LESSON.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO LISTEN TO
ME, LISTEN TO THIS GUY.
>> WE NEED TO TEACH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY A LESSON THAT
THEY WILL NEVER FORGET THAT YOU
DON'T MESS WITH OUR SYSTEM,
DON'T AFT WITH OUR DUE PROCESS
AND YOU DO NOT LET SOMEBODY IS
DONE ACCUSATION.
GREG: I LOVE TALKING TO MYSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
WE ARE NOT SAVAGES WITH TORCHES
AND PITCHFORKS ANYMORE.
WE ARE CIVILIZED.
EVERYTHING AWFUL IN THIS WORLD
HAD TO START SOMEWHERE FIRST.
THE ELECTION IS WHEN YOU TRY TO
STOP IT BEFORE IT GETS ANY
WORSE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GUESTS, HE
SPELLED DOOM IN THE COURTROOM,
ATTORNEY EMILY.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HE IS A COMEDIAN, RADIO HOST IN
YOUR UBER DRIVER, FOX NEWS HOST
THOMPSON LOOP.
SHE IS SO BRIGHT GLOW WORMS
FOLLOW HER HOME.
NATIONAL REVIEW REPORTER, KAT
TIMPF.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND HE CAN LITERALLY REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE, FORMER WWE
SUPERSTAR IN MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
EMILY, YOU ARE A LAWYER AND I'LL
BE HONEST, I DID NOT CARE ABOUT
THIS WHOLE PROCESS NOMINATION
BUT IS SOMETHING I FELT WAS OUT
OF MY POWER AND IT JUST HAPPENED
BUT I DID NOT CARE ABOUT THE
STORY UNTIL THE LEFT WHEN WE
CARE ABOUT IT.
IT GOT ME MAD, THE INTIMATION IN
LIFE AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
WE SAW A PRECIOUS GET SUBVERTED.
>> THE PROCESS WAS ONE 100%
IGNORED.
THAT WAS THE POINT.
I THINK, AS AN ATTORNEY,
FIRSTHAND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
COURT ACCEPTS AS TRUE
ALLEGATIONS OF STATEMENTS THAT
ARE UNCOOPERATIVE.
EVERY CHARACTER WITNESS FOR TWO
SEPARATE FALSE ACCUSATION TRIAL
TRIALS.
I SAW THAT THE RIPPLE EFFECT CAN
BE OVERSTATED IN OF COURSE, I
SUPPORT THE NEED TO MOVEMENT AND
PROFESSIONALLY AND POSIT
PERSONALLY BUT ONE DOES NOT
EQUATE THE OTHER.
IT'S RIDICULOUS SUBVERSION OF
JUSTICE TO ACCEPT ALLEGATIONS.
THAT GENDER AUTOMATICALLY IS A
TRUTH DOES NO ONE ANY GOOD,
WHATSOEVER.
GREG: TOM, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
AGREE WITH KAVANAUGH'S
PHILOSOPHIES AND I DON'T THINK
THE VOTE WAS ABOUT THAT ANYMORE.
THE VOTE WAS A DEFENSE OF THE
SYSTEM AND THE DEFENSE OF DUE
PROCESS.
>> AND I LIKE WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE MOB.
I ALMOST TEARED UP.
GREG: REALLY?
IB ALLERGIES.
>> I'VE BEEN EMOTIONAL ALL WEEK.
OUR GREAT HERO ANDREW BREITBART,
ALWAYS SPOKE ABOUT WHAT DROVE
HIM TO BECOME POLITICAL AND IT
WAS THE CLARENCE THOMAS HEARING
THAT HE WOULD ALWAYS SAY THAT.
THE ANGER HE FELT WHEN A MAN
WITH DUE PROCESS BEING TORN OUT
IN THE CASE HE BECAME THE
RIGHT-WING ACTIVISTS THAT WE ALL
KNOW AND LOVE AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY IT WILL
BE THE SAME THING.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE I PEOPLE
CALLING ON MY RADIO SHOW, A LOT
OF WOMEN, CALLING MY SHOW SAYING
I DO NOT LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING.
I HAVE BROTHERS AND HUSBANDS AND
SONS.
GREG: MOST OF THOSE CALLS ARE
RUN NUMBERS.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THE NUMBERS ARE CLOSE TO A
FAST FOOD RESTAURANT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> BUT THEY ALL CALL IN.
GREG: CAP, THE LESSON FOR ME AND
YOU CAN AGREE OR DISAGREE OR I
PREFER YOU TO AGREE BUT IS
TYRANNY ABOUT THE LOUD OF YOU
WHO SEEK TO INTIMIDATE THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC AND THAT THE
ULTIMATE GOAL AND THAT'S HOW I
FEEL AND HOW YOU FEEL?
KAT: I THINK THAT'S A THING.
[LAUGHTER]
, I THINK IT WAS TOUGH AND I WAS
WATCHING THIS AND THINKING TO
MYSELF I AM SO GLAD THAT I AM
NOT A SENATOR.
I HAD THE HARDEST TIME TODAY
DECIDING WHETHER I WANTED
CHICKEN OR BEEF ON MY BBQ BOWL
AND THAT IS SLIGHTLY LESS
CONFIDENTIAL ON THE SIDING
SHOULD SIT ON THE HIGHEST COURT
IN THE LAND.
GREG: RIGHT, RIGHT.
KAT: BUT AS ALLUDED TO EARLIER,
WE HAVE MICHAEL AVE AND ATT I TO
THINK FOR THIS.
WE BROUGHT UP THE INCREDIBLE
GANG RAPE ALLEGATIONS STORIES
AND MADE PEOPLE TUNE OUT AND
WATCHING DOCTOR FOR TESTIMONY
WAS AN EMOTIONAL THING AND I
WATCH THAT AND I HAD A TOUGH
TIME DECIDING WHO TO BELIEVE AND
I THINK THEY BROUGHT OUT THE
GANG RAPE STUFF LISTENING TO ALL
THAT AND THEY WERE MORE WILLING
TO BELIEVE BRETT KAVANAUGH SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THE WHITE HOUSE
SENT HIM A THANK YOU CARD OR AN
EDIBLE ARRANGEMENT.
GREG: MICHAEL AVENATTI EXCITED
MORE REPUBLICANS THAN FOX NEWS.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: I THOUGHT THAT WAS FUNNIER
IN MY HEAD.
TYRUS -- MAC.
GREG: NO PITY APPLAUSE.
TYRUS, IT'S AMAZING HOW THIS
TRAVESTY LOOKS WHEN YOU LOOK --
TWO WEEKS AGO WHEN YOU'RE INSIDE
OF IT IT SEEMS SO HORRIBLE AND
UGLY NOW WHEN YOU STEP OUT IT
SEEMS LIKE DID THAT REALLY
HAPPEN?
TYRUS: I DID MY BEST NOT TO GET
IN IT.
WHEN IT COMES TO JUDGES IN SOUTH
BY TEN DO NOT WANT TO BE AROUND
IT.
I DON'T HAVE GREAT EXPENSES WITH
JUDGES IN GENERAL I TRY TO AVOID
THEM LIKE THE PLAGUE.
BUT TO GO BACK, MICHAEL AVENATTI
I KNOW WERE LAUGHING ABOUT IT
BUT HE CONCERNS ME BECAUSE HE
WAS USING FEAR AND CRAZY
ALLEGATIONS TO RUIN SOME OF LIFE
AND MOVE HIMSELF AHEAD AND WHEN
THERE HAS TO BE SOME TYPE OF
LEGAL FOR SOMEONE TO COME OUT
AND DO WHAT HE DID AND THEN HE
CAN REGROUP AND DO IT AGAIN.
GREG: THAT'S THE THING.
THE AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION IS
TALKING ABOUT HOW CONCERNED THEY
ARE OVER KAVANAUGH AND THEY NOT
SAID ANYTHING ABOUT MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
HE SHOULD BE DISBARRED.
TYRUS: HE IS USING PEOPLE TO
ADVANCE HIMSELF.
EVEN STORMY DANIELS, LISTEN,
SHE'S HAD A ROUGH LIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I DON'T THINK IF YOU LOOK
WHEN HISTORY LOOKS BACK, HE EVER
SERVED HER WELL.
SHE HAD TO PAY THE MONEY BACK.
KAT: THE WHITE HOUSE SENT THE
MONEY BACK.
TYRUS: NO ONE WILL WANT TO BUY
HER STORY AND SO HERE HIT HER
WITH A BAD BILL.
HE DOES NOT HELP ANYONE.
MAYBE HE'S A SECRET AGENT FOR
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
GREG: HE DID MORE HELP OTHER
PLUG-INS THEN SURPRISE